tant qu'on parle de science parce que
cette semaine ya des astronautes
canadiens qui ont annoncé avoir
découvert des indices d'un des plus
mystérieux phénomène de l'univers
d'étranges signaux extraterrestres qu'on
appelle des sursauts radio rapide et
donc ça donne du fil à retorde ça aux
astrophysiciens depuis une décennie
mais il ya un nouveau télescope
construit au canada
renault manuguerra ganic est avec moi
pour en parler renault a ajouté des scot
bonjour qui pourrait aider à percer le
mystère
oui dans cette semaine devrait aussi une
cinquantaine de chercheurs canadiens qui
ont vraiment de qui viennent
d'université partout à travers le pays
qui ont vraiment marqué l'histoire de
l'astronomie si on peut dire ils ont
annoncé la détection du deuxième sur
sous radio rapide de l'histoire donc ces
phénomènes la cdci nyon extrêmement
puissant très bref qui viennent de très
loin dans l'univers et on n'a pas la
moindre idée de ce que c'est c'est
vraiment un grand mystère
on les observe une soixantaine de fois
depuis une décennie
mais ils ont toujours été très difficile
à étudier parce que à une exception près
c'est toujours des phénomènes unique
c'est un flash ça arrive une fois et on
le revoit jamais mais à l'aide du
radiotélescope shame qui se trouve en
colombie britannique
mais des chercheurs qui ont détecté
cette deuxième source qui se répétaient
de l'histoire donc et beaucoup plus
faciles à étudier et ça c'est très
prometteur pour ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est vraiment comprendre c'est quoi ce
mystère là oui c'est ça on parle de
mystère mais qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est
exactement ça aurait phénomène renault
mais le phénomène a été observé pour la
première fois en 2007 donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez récent séquence est arrivé
c'était vraiment un phénomène étrange de
certaines très puissantes émissions
d'ondés radio que duré quelques
millisecondes après puis qu'après et qui
s'est éteinte sans explication donc la
plupart des objets dans l'univers
émettent des ondes électromagnétiques et
son plan cap t on peut en capter les
fréquents sous la forme d' onde radio
les mêmes sons de radios que les médias
utilisent pour transmettre leurs
informations un peu partout donc le
soleil les planètes des nuages de gaz
dans l'univers tout ça à aimer saison de
radio et la nature du signal peut nous
permettre de savoir quel objet on est en
train d'observer mais en plus plus un
signal vient de loin plus il doit être
puissant pour qu'on puisse être détecté
sur terre et les sursauts radio rapide
ça c'est des signaux qui viennent d'
extrêmement loin on parle de milliards
d'années lumière
la terre est si on est capable de capter
ces signaux leur ici ça veut dire que
l'objet à la source est incroyablement
puissant en fait avec les signes qu'on
les signes ou qu'on a reçu les
chercheurs qui ont calculé que cet objet
l'a aimée en quelques millisecondes
autant d'énergie que le soleil émet en
dix mille ans on sait pas ce que c'est
mais c'est quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant et avec cette vitesse là
ça va être dur il a étudié j'imagine oui
est en fait en plus les premiers signaux
qui ont été détectés étaient très bref
c'était un flash la pression les voyait
plus donc dans ces conditions le sait
quelque chose qui est difficile à
étudier en 2012 on ne détecte une
première source à 3 milliards
d'années-lumière de la terre qui se
répétaient donc un peu comme un phare
comme la lumière d'un phare qui tourne
est ce ça intéressait beaucoup les
chercheurs parce qu'il pouvait lire dans
ces conditions les faits l'étudier mais
en recherche on a toujours besoin d'eux
obligé de toujours besoin de comparer un
objet un autre dont il nous en fallait
un deuxième est celle où il sait que les
chercheurs canadiens arrivent avec leur
radiotélescope shy'm qui a été inaugurée
en 2017 en colombie britannique c'est
une énorme structure qui fait d'eux la
la taille de deux terrains de football
et son bus a été d'étudier les grandes
structures de l'univers en détectant
saison de radio l'ajustement et au mois
d'août dernier alors que le télescope
était dans sa phase de test mais il a
capturé ces répétitions qui était cette
deuxième source que les chercheurs
attendaient ils voulaient découvrir et
se situer à 1.5 milliards
d'années-lumière de la terre donc c'est
deux fois plus près que la sauce
précédente et donc avec une preuve en
premier succès aussi rapide de l'eau les
chercheurs espèrent enfin capable de
savoir c'est quoi cet objet mystérieux
locke et mais le signal wi et j'imagine
qu'ils y vont avec plein disposition
qu'est ce que ça peut être le héros
n'est simple en théorie à gauche à
droite il ya certains qui pensent que
c'est des étoiles qui tombe très
rapidement sur elle-même comme des
étoiles à neutrons d'autres qui pensent
que c'est des étoiles qui explose donc
qui pensent que c'est des trous noirs et
comme n'importe quel autre phénomène
mystérieux qu'on s'est passé quoi qu'une
l'espace y en a même qui ont émis
l'hypothèse que c'était un signal qui
veut utiliser une civilisation
extraterrestre mais sans cette hypothèse
le est un petit peu plus farfelues mais
en attendant les chercheurs vont
continuer d'étudier et vont même s'en
servir comme outil pour étudier
l'univers essaie de comprendre le monde
dans lequel on était de tester les
théories donc ces phénomènes qui va être
assez intéressant qu'on va suivre au
cours de l'année qui s'en vient festina
et les gens qui ont des questions pour
vous pour vous écrire
directement sur votre adresse et on peut
revoir la chronique sur la page facebook
de rdi matin comme chaque fois parfait
merci à vous